[Music]
it looks really weird it's never coming
to my life I've seen it at restaurants
whenever friends do try it I'm always
hesitant I rarely went to a place that
served it and then when I was there I
was like that looks too weird I'm gonna
have the chicken I can't pronounce
instead this is like classic boba sealed
I hope that it tastes like chocolate
milk it just felt like tadpoles blew in
my mouth I don't know how I feel about
chewing these weird gummy things like
chewing on a trampoline I'm like
pleasantly surprised the tea is
delicious is very similar to like this
Indian cha I like it better don't we get
it it's like expecting to get a Game Boy
for Christmas and then your parents get
you a Game Boy Advance Oh totally go for
this again this looks like a witch's
brew I have no idea what Tarot is boo -
go ahead I really like it I like it more
than the first one it's a floral kind of
sweet potato kind of favorite sweet but
not too sweet chewing on something
matches the flavor of what's going on
here I would prefer the tea without the
boba honeydew note T this does not look
natural at all this is really good woah
that tastes exactly like honeydew so
sweet and so sour at the same time we're
really powerful it's not too sweet this
makes the most sense to chew that balls
cuz you're used to chewing when you eat
how you do feel like honeydew is done
better in boba than it is like on its
own I'm liking it more and more maybe I
need to go on and start drinking more
boba tea it almost makes drinking tea
stressful I'm a convert I like the
squishy I would drink this now I'm glad
I tried it these balls confused me a
time I don't know whether this wall um
or just like let them hang out in my
mouth it's it's impossible not to make
jokes about balls in your drinking this
team